l'état de droit il peut il est de plus
en plus combattu il comprit même au sein
de l'instance dirigeante
on trouve que ne serait ce que pour
combattre le terrorisme par exemple on
trouve que l'état de droit ça devient un
peu embarrassant l'idée de d'emprisonner
les fichiers s il ya beaucoup de gens au
sein de au sein d'eads et de nos
dirigeants politiques qui sont qui sont
pour par exemple quand bien même ces
gens là n'ont encore rien fait on ne
fait que les soupçonner de pouvoir faire
quelque chose un jour mais on se dit il
vaudrait peut-être mieux les enfermer
quand même l'idée de deux interdire de
manifester par exemple c'est quelque
chose qui est contre il va à l'encontre
de l'état de droit mais on pourrait en
citer énormément le nombre de nos
libertés qui ont été réduites au cours
des deux de ces cas ce dernier a tanné
cc considérable est de plus en plus des
politiques disent pas on doit pouvoir
faire de la politique sans demander la
permission aux juges ce qui veut dire en
fait ne plus se soucier de l'état de
droit
effectivement mon ya 7 jan
il n'y a qu'à sayat cette tendance dans
des pays qui en principe dix ont
identifié plus ou moins représentation
démocratie état de droit brouilla via
yahia disons cette tendance de plus en
plus fectivement dirais à 10 ont su se
dégager en quelque sorte des contraintes
de l'état de droit alors évidemment
c'est toujours un peu le disons le fond
le même processus à savoir que au fond
il ya des mots des mots qui permettent
une seule façon de s'en sortir quoi de
se sortir précisément des contraintes
normal quoi
bon il ya le mot terrorisme bon le mot
sécurité où on voit bien qu'il ya bondé
ce sont des mots qu à la fois désigne
des réalités monteiro ritz a désigné
réalité terrible bon ça y'a pas de
particuliers là-dessus quoi mais en même
temps ça ah bon ça ça désigne quelque
chose aussi comme une espèce de grande
nébuleuse à savoir que terrorisme disent
on va pas se mettre à désigne pas
seulement des activités précises des
réseaux spéciaux qui disons qu'ils aient
coquisart coordonne ces activités
mais une sorte d'états du monde quand
une sorte d'états du monde de danger un
peu planant sur le monde est
effectivement azuelos moment la bomba
puisque c'est le terrorisme à ce moment
là disons on est plus d'heureux dans les
règles du jeu donc on peut soi-même
sortir
règles du jeu ou quad bon c'est là le
mot sécurité house is a eu aussi ce
disons ce rôle là quoi à savoir que ont
défini quelque chose comme des menaces
pesant sur l'état de droit qui justifie
le fait que bien en en disant on se
libère d'abidjan cet état de droit c'est
une espèce de logique et on voit bien
que ce qui se passe par exemple
aujourd'hui dans les manifestations en
france quoi bon c'est vrai que ça
devient difficile de manifester des
bénéfices de manifester parce que bon
effectivement d'une part y ait des gens
qui ont interdit de manifester
c'est effectivement une fois tout à fait
incroyable quoi disons les interdictions
individuel de manifester c'est quand
même chose qui me gêne particulière quoi
et puis bon il ya un fait que bon ben on
n'a plus trop envie de manifester ou on
se met sur le côté on se met sur le côté
sur un trottoir et un peu à l'écart
parce que baptise on parle effectivement
là disons les forces de l'ordre se sont
dotés d'armes qui sont désarmés
extraordinairement violente et que bon
disons au fond ils et elles sont
justifiées digitimes est bon à l'employé
quoi c'est là qu'on voit justement que
voilà qu'on tourne quand on parle de
libéralisme de gouvernements libéraux
que ça sera non enfin je dirais que au
fond de nos gouvernants gouvernement
gouvernements dits libéraux sont des
gouvernements qui de plus en plus
effectivement eu rogne sur ceux qui
étaient censés et encore c'est beaucoup
à discuter à être l'essence même un
petit peu du du libéralisme comme
idéologie
[Musique]